in manual and gauri won't let his voter
card out of his hands last month the
refugee went to the authorities in yola
to pick it up himself he says it isn't a
problem that the presidential election
was postponed by six weeks he has
learned to be patient in the refugee
camp I'm not disappointed I'm even
playing that there should be more time
to be given safe so that they we should
get our screw t intact more than two
thousand refugees live in this camp near
yola almost all have fled their villages
for fear of attacks by the Islamist
terror group Boko Haram the Gurry family
had to watch how government soldiers
were hopelessly outnumbered when boko
haram attacked their village now they
simply cannot imagine the government
will restore control in just six weeks
our military one day I had these people
kept coming they were they want even
telling our people to run away because
they're having overpowered by the
insurgents you see one day soon as we
are only holding their shares journalist
Edgar Amos is also a refugee from the
embattled north he says security
problems weren't the reason for the
delay to election he believes it's all
down to politics the ruling party needs
more time to gain some political mileage
perhaps they are threatened by the
apparent acceptability of the opposition
probably if the elections are postponed
maybe to give them more time to
restructure eyes it doesn't matter to a
manual Hungary what political games are
behind the delay he and his family say
all they hope is that the elections
really do take place six weeks from now
everywhere nigeria people every man come
after the news of the postponement of
the elections many Nigerians say that
they don't want to give the government
any reason to postpone them again but
they also emphasize should the elections
not to take place in six weeks that they
will definitely start to lose their
patience